I am appalled I am upset they stop to
the fact that I have access to 100
million dollars worth of equipment and I
still cannot do as good a cancer
diagnosis as the humblest dog that has
been trained for a few months mi t--'s
Andres Martian thinks an artificial nose
could become the most powerful
diagnostic tool in history and remake
medicine forever which is why he's been
working on building a machine that works
as well as a dog's nose to create after
all dogs can detect explosives with
their noses and sniff out all sorts of
medical conditions
from seizures to diabetes to cancers
with up to 98% accuracy in some cases
but when Mershon set out to make a
robotic nose he realized how little we
even know about how smell works what are
the major benefits of my phone being
able to smell me your phone already has
and I called the camera but it has an
ear it's called a microphone
these seven nose now what does it need
to learn nose why does your cellphone
need to have a nose it needs to know
single eyes see the small I have here
yeah it might turn melanoma tomorrow I
won't know what changed shape or color
my dog if I had a dog trained to detect
cancer would tell you immediately now
you wait six months and it might be a
death sentence early diagnosis that the
dogs can do routinely is the difference
between life and death if you have a
diabetic child you have to prick their
finger every two hours while they're
asleep imagine a situation of having to
live in that animal your life is
controlled by this disease and dog can
cure this by sleeping on a different
floor than the baby will alert you
minute minutes before there is a problem
if my phone smells me they in there and
learns what my normal centers and alerts
me to a medical condition so they can
save my life
that is a good thing I want the phone to
do this we're already carrying these
things we're always literally sleeping
with these things
these things you need to do more first
so I read that dogs are 90 percent
accurate if they've been trained at
detecting things like prostate cancer
I was wondering if you could run through
what else dogs can detect so far every
cancer that has ever been tried to be
detected by dogs has actually been a
deadly successfully not every cancer has
been tracked everything else that we
have tried properly or or even at how I
hang including malaria and Parkinson's
has worked that doesn't mean it on to my
editor doesn't mean that there's no
limit to what they can do it's just too
soon yet some of these dogs when they
are trained on one cancer let's say
bladder cancer they will spontaneously
recognize a different type of cancer
that has no identical bullet outs no
other system in the world business
nothing that's what a good dogs are the
earliest least false positive least
false negatives cheapest fastest cancer
detectors we have it seems like the dogs
are reading the molecules you know the
bottom hole it was a coming through note
they're reading them but they're not
reading just them they're reading
something written on public it's like
the molecules are the fonts that the
message is in the dog's mind to be able
to interpret of thought the font the
font yeah the models are the fonts the
message cancer no cancer bad cancer good
cancer which the dogs can tell us he's
not written on anything that has to do
with the structure of each molecule it
is emerged by suddenly the dogs do as
observers of this why are dogs so much
better than us and better than computers
currently at smelling disease the
facetious but 90% true answer is because
the nose is closer to the ground here's
why most of the odorants the molecules
that confer the sensor 7 a new surfaces
please
soil wall etc having your nose close to
surface makes me more more acutely aware
of it and it makes it more important to
your University dogs are very very keen
on breeding the universe using their
nose almost a skin is we are unit
reading are you accusing our eyes they
see things
in the ground that we don't see if you
look at where somebody has stepped with
an infrared camera if they are not
wearing any shoes you will see their
steps left behind as heat the dumps it's
the same image only using his his or her
nose they see what somebody has been by
ingesting and and pressing this bloom of
odorants what is the biggest challenge
with artificial olfaction the biggest
challenge with artificial infection I
think is still in the psychological is
not longer in the technological realm we
have devices that can detect odorants to
a lower concentration that the
best-known available about virginal nose
can do what we are trying to understand
is it how the dogs detect the utterance
we already know that we've built a dog
analog as far as the sectional area goes
well we have noticed the dog's
intelligence layer how does a dog upon
training realize what is what how far
away are we from having your artificial
nose in a phone I do not know the answer
to how long until my device is in your
phone what will happen once it's in
there is we will enter a whole new era
of Medicine
it's as simple as that what can building
an artificial nose tell us about how
scent works
we thought that when you sniffing what
happens is you get a list of molecules
by name and concentration it's like like
a recipe if I tell you the recipe of a
perfume all the molecules as a list of
names and concentration will you know
what it smells like
no neither will it chemist neither will
somebody who's trained very well even a
trained really well they'll still be
surprised the only thing we know is
science kindly that is legit and sort of
an ambiguous and we haven't seen an
exception is that nothing above above
400 molecular weight smells that's all
we know I always thought that in order
to build something you first didn't need
to know how it works
and then you build it but if you really
think about it that's not how the world
works
the Wright brothers did not know how
flag works on the plane anyway under
circles we did not know how nose works
without the nose now innocent errors in
building it we were actually slapped by
the universe into understanding how
old-fashioned actually works okay there
meaning you attach the scent has to do
with your experience with it at the same
time there's some meanings are attached
there before you even get born for
instance my daughter taught me this my
daughter was three when I was changing
my son's diaper who was one of the time
she comes in the room and says what's
that smell Betty I asked her question
what does it smell tell you I don't want
to eat it
exactly right literally I want our
phones to smell us if my phone smells me
they in there and learns what my normal
scent is an alerts me to medical
conditions so they can say well okay
that is a good thing when I'm pregnant
my sense of smell because of hormones is
hyper active and I can smell so many
different things
what does artificial olfaction tell us
about subjective olfaction in biological
beings if you pregnant scent character
changes that's just an exaggerated
instance of something that happens to
all of us all the time the olfactory
palate of the human is about 30% viable
in human to human when you're pregnant
you're not more subjective you're more
in a sense objective your body tells you
what you need and what you don't need by
modulating you want some desires from
the olfactory spectrum races my wife she
is obsessed with coffee and when she's
reading the she hates pot which is
insane because my wife will drink I am
better knowing she's pregnant now what
does that mean that means that your body
thing control over your over your
perception it's called perceptual
engineering your body know that there's
something important going on that needs
to engineer your perception towards
different items it makes you want and
look at and pay attention to different
things big way of doing this under the
radar you don't even know that it's
happening
the amount of things that will faction
plugs into as far as your behavior goes
is it safe some people are blind to
certain orders and same as certain
colors you might perceive a sensation of
order and that might or might not cause
you to behave a certain way be a first
he attracted me say hmm I want to eat
this hmm I don't wanna eat this things
like this right similar division you
might see something you're attracted you
might see something you want to run away
from right having a sense of smell it
can be also predictive of health right
and losing your sense of smell in some
cases I've seen research can be an
indicator of dementia later on the most
the most accurate predictor of
Alzheimer's that we have currently as
far as I understand is a decrement in
the threshold of detection of certain
order X how about this if you have this
let's say early onset back Parkinson's
which is a documented case you will
start being a less able
discriminate between let's say garlic
and onion I read that 53 percent of
young people would rather lose their
sense of scent and their sense of smell
than lose their phone which I think
brings to mind the idea that scent and
the sense of smell is a really on
valued cents no it brings the idea that
phones are very valuable thing I would
lose my sense of smell
my sense of smell before I lose my phone
and I am a smell researcher Wow because
this thing gives me power more power
than my nose does Andres let me ask you
you just said and I was frankly shocked
that you would rather give up your sense
of smell than give up your cellphone
would you only do that if you were if
you knew your phone would be equipped
with a sense of smell I would not give
up my sense of vision okay that's too
important but my sense of smell the kind
way that I'm using it is not important
enough to me yes it is good to have
power I knows most people don't use it
the body can do incredible things do
most rescue this has been fascinating I
have a thank you so much for your time
you guys are great thank you
[Music]